all right we
are now live for the august
ama that is ask me anything session i'm
starting a little bit early since i see
there's already
a lot of questions here some of which
i'm going to skip
over if they're far too generic like
what philosophy
is that's uh one that that's
answered in in some of my videos already
so
let's let's take a look at the first one
this is from dale do i have any advice
on reading poetry and where to start i
often struggle to understand what i read
and feel like i'm forcing a meaning
i don't have a lot of advice about
reading poetry because i'm i'm not a
poetry guy
but um i would say that
you don't have to feel as if you're
under great pressure to
understand a poem the first time around
or to come up with the right
uh viewpoint on it and understand too
that there's a lot of different kinds of
poetry right there isn't just
one single type so if you're reading
homer
obviously that's epic poetry and that's
you know
um probably not going to come across all
that much
in terms of our way of under
understanding poetry with end
rhyme and you know they use meter
instead in ancient greek stuff or
ancient
ancient latin but you can you know
figure out what the themes are
you know read commentaries there's
plenty of people out there for any
important piece of poetry that have
already written things that i think that
you could
easily find you know at the local
library or
online and you know it's it's a
cumulative process
just like reading literature of other
types just
like reading philosophy just like
reading history the first time around
you you don't expect to get everything
reiko asks am i excited for the new dune
movie i'd even forgotten that a new dune
movie is coming out so
obviously not particularly excited but
you know i'm willing to
give it a a watch we'll see how it goes
you know adaptations of great sci-fi
epics pretty hit and miss
um so for me the bar is is pretty low
um in thinking about you know how it's
going to be i mean
i didn't think that the david lynch one
was was as terrible as so many people
have made it out to be
i wouldn't want to try to have to make
dune without having like an entire mini
series at my disposal
uh tulias any tips or things to keep in
mind with reading cicero's on duties
um yeah i mean you could you could keep
in mind that
like i just said about poetry um it's
not something for it's not a text for
you to master
it's something for you to learn from and
learn in multiple ways and on multiple
levels
before you worry about whether you think
cicero has got something right or not
figure out what he's actually saying and
make sure that you you solidly
understand that
if you see what appear to you to be
contradictions in it you should always
say
wow maybe cicero's actually smarter than
me
and maybe these aren't the
contradictions that i think they are and
i need to
re-examine my own viewpoint coming to it
and then you know there will be some
things you probably disagree with and
that's okay
um figure out why you disagree with them
right and see if you can articulate um
what precisely you disagree with and and
what you
you do agree with those are things that
would apply to almost any philosophical
text though
galen i've heard more than a few people
say that nietzsche contributed nothing
original and just rehashed a bunch of
older stuff what are some responses or
resources to point them to
so one great response is hey buddy
you're full of [ __ ]
right because i mean that's a silly
thing to say
that nietzsche contributed nothing
original the burden of proof is
kind of on them to make that case
it's not on you to argue for nietzsche
or something like that i mean
an adequate reading of just a few of
nietzsche's works
will introduce you to some pretty cool
and
pretty original ideas obviously it's not
all just like made up out of his head
he is responding to the situation of his
time and
incorporating a lot of people you know
heidegger actually thought that before
you read nietzsche you
should spend a lot of time reading
aristotle and interestingly enough
um that's probably got more to do with
heidegger than with actual nietzsche but
i think that your
your many people are probably just full
of crap
and i would i wouldn't even bother
engaging them
um to me that's that's you know it
reminds me of a professor who
he had for a short time before she
actually like fizzled out and became a
self-help guru
when i was in grad school who saw us
carrying you know
hegel's phenomenology around she's like
why would anyone want to read
hegel you know and i was like wow this
is one dumb
person so i i kind of think people
saying things like that that nietzsche
contributed nothing original and just
rehashed a bunch of older stuff
ask him what older older stuff they they
think that he got it from
you know that'll be quite a tell right
there
matthew says i'm currently stubborn
stumbling through birth of tragedy
could you talk about the ontological
nature of the dionysian apollonian are
they structures of the mind or some
other metaphysical state your videos
help lots
yeah i've talked about this a lot in my
videos
nietzsche calls them two of the three
noble responses to life so that should
tell you what their ontological status
is right there
you know and if you look through the
work and it's going to take a couple
times going through it you'll see that
they are themselves perspectives on
metaphysics but they also
embody a certain metaphysics you should
also keep in mind though that the
apollonian and dionysian
are not always the same thing they're
different nietzsche says
the dionysian for the greeks is
different than it is for the barbarians
neither one of them is the the main show
that's actually being discussed there so
if you think that everything's
a duality between the two you've misread
nietzsche as so many people
especially artists and other creative
people reading
the birth of tragedy have done for now
about a hundred years
the socratic alexandrian response is
even
more important from nietzsche's
perspective
than those those two the apollonian and
dionysian so you want to
take all three of those into
consideration
um james says
is it difficult to go from reading and
translating classical latin to medieval
latin and the same but with attic and
koine greek
if so which do you think is more
difficult to make the jump with i would
put that sort of
perspective totally out of your mind i
wouldn't even worry about that
it depends on the person it depends on
the author it depends on the text
right reading you know aristotle
is different than reading plato is
different than reading um
xenophon is different than reading you
know uh
poetry like like uh specialists right
um and then there are people who are
deliberately at a cyst like
lucian of sam soda there are there are
some authors who are kind of like on the
way to coin a
like aristotle himself you can see some
of the things developing
koine also includes people like
epictetus
right not just biblical greek and
there's a lot of silliness
out there about you know the the two of
these things attic versus coin a
it was really a much more complicated
picture same thing with like classical
versus
medieval latin who's medieval latin are
we talking about
thomas aquinas who deliberately made his
writings
very simple to read or are we talking
about somebody who's a bit more
complex like anselm of canterbury right
these sort of generalizations are not
often very helpful for people
the thing to do is study the stuff you
know there are books out there that you
can find
with a little bit of research that will
uh introduce you to some of the
interesting transformations that happen
in medieval latin uh in terms of sound
in terms of vocabulary in terms of other
things
um so you know that's that it's starting
from some non-starters i would say
uh aberdolf says if earth was built by
aliens because our existence somehow
powers their cars is our meaning the one
we and ignorance believe in or the one
given to us
could we still live at peace knowing the
truth uh if we replace the car
powering purpose with survival we
describe life don't we everything has to
lead to survival oh that's a little
unclear at the end
um what's to prevent there being
multiple meanings
i mean you know if if uh if my water
bottle became
sentient and started i don't know
studying dance or something like that
why couldn't that be part of the meaning
of its life
in addition to being a water bottle
constructed by us
humans for a certain purpose
i don't see any any incompatibility
between these
why force a dilemma when there doesn't
have to be one why couldn't there be a
surplus of meaning
you know bad or rust what do you think
is the best way to run a philosophy and
beer meetup that is people who barely
understand what philosophy that just
that isn't just the very basic stuff um
so far we've touched on topics like
berkeley's idealism paradoxes licensing
patience nature's eternal recurrence not
teaching these topics but getting them
to
question things do you think this is a
good direction i mean i think there's
multiple good directions right
if if you have a philosophy and beer
meetup and the people
at the meetup don't really know much
about philosophy and your goal is not to
actually like talk
a lot about philosophy
you can pick any topic you like right
you pick current events you can pick
you know um i mean berkeley's idealism
is
is kind of an interesting idea to to
work with
um ideally you're going to want unless
you just want it to be a [ __ ]
session which
which could be perfectly fine
you're going to want them to start
reading texts and
doing more than just like throwing their
ideas on the table or something like
that
so you know you think of it as sort of
like a gateway
procedure drug or something like that
but yeah why not i mean you know with
our
milwaukee stoic fellowship we have
people when we meet face to face who
have very little background in stoicism
and often have all sorts of
wrong-headed ideas that they got from
reading
popular writers about it who steered
them wrong
you know and then you know we we talk
about it but we we steer them towards
actual engagement with the philosophy
otherwise it's
it's treating philosophy as sort of like
just a topic of conversation
like a commodity there's nothing
inherently wrong with that
i mean if what you want to do is sit
around and drink some beer
and shoot the [ __ ] and pepper it with
philosophical stuff nothing wrong with
that right
if you want it to be something more then
you probably have to introduce a bit
more
structure and direction to it
poppy have i read parfit
eddie parfit what do i think of him i'm
currently reading reasons and persons
and i find him to be nothing short of a
genius
wish he was still alive i think genius
is a word that
i don't use in part because i think that
it's just shorthand for whatever woo
somebody wants to put into it um
parfit is an intelligent person i think
he's pretty overrated
um but i think a lot of people in in
20th century analytic philosophy are
pretty overrated a lot of it reinvention
of wheels
um due to the you know not reading
historical texts and
and um you know he's got some
interesting ideas just like nozick has
some interesting ideas just like ryle
has some interesting ideas lots of
people have interesting ideas
is he a genius i don't think so
i mean i don't even call hagel a genius
or
heidegger a genius because like i said i
think that the word genius is
is basically tapped out
um i mean i might eventually do some
some videos on
on some things but he'd be really low
priority for me
it's could you explain the argument
against change created by
permanities there isn't an argument
against change created by permanentes
there is a poem
in which parmenides articulates a
position
that holds that there isn't any real
change
and you can easily get and read the poem
so i and i've got some videos out there
on it i don't think i need to rehash
that uh
poppy have you read joyce's ulysses
isn't it magnificent
i thought it was crap and i quit reading
it about 20 pages in
again there's people are going to
disagree with me on this there's a lot
of things that
i come to and i and people are like oh
you've got to read this it's an opus
it's a it's amazing and i come to it you
know with these very high expectations
and i'm like
you know after a while i'm like i don't
really care about
this this author this book i got better
stuff to do i
i could be reading something you know
instead of reading ulysses i'd rather
read uh
mervin peak and the gorman gas stuff if
i want something that's beautiful lush
prose
but it's actually going somewhere i'll
read the gorman gas trilogy
right or i'll read borehase or i'll read
any of these these other authors now you
know some people really really get
into james joyce and some people think
that ulysses is like this
amazing wonderful thing i didn't have
that that experience when i
read it uh back in college and was kind
of uh
disappointed with the people who were
talking it up so much
all right uh whim says do i have any
tips for people starting out with
philosophy i'm a second year bachelor
student aspiring to an academic career
um well before i'd aspire to an academic
career i would you know spend
some time with the discipline and see
whether it's really for you
and then you know look at the the sca
you know the projections for what an
academic career is going to be like and
decide whether
you're cool with the sacrifices that
you're probably going to have to make
in order to have an academic career
tips for people starting out with for
with philosophy i've got a bunch of
videos
on that sort of stuff including in my
intro philosophy playlist so
you could check those out i will just
throw a few
out there one is a reiteration of what i
said earlier
when you're reading a philosophical text
you're not going to get everything
that's in the text
in any sort of systematic progressive
way on the first
reading probably not on the even on the
10th reading and if it's a great work
you're probably going to be like me 20
years later
still finding stuff that you missed
before
so don't put that pressure upon yourself
that you have to like totally understand
the philosophical
text i mean don't don't you know cut
yourself too much slack and say oh i can
make of this whatever i want or i don't
have to read it i can just watch
videos or listen to podcasts you know
you really do have to
you want to talk about nietzsche
competently you've got to have read
nietzsche and spend some time with him
or
if you want to talk about um plato you
know you have to have spent a good bit
of time with with plato
um but it's it's a cumulative process
and you
often don't realize when you're putting
the work
in how much you are building until later
on when
suddenly you've got this stuff available
up in your headspace that you can bring
out
into a a conversation so i'd say that's
probably
a uh a useful tip right there
ethan bills what are your thoughts on
ooo and speculative realism more
generally i don't know what
is that's probably something pertaining
to speculative realism
um i think speculative realism is an
interesting fad
sort of like radical orthodoxy or all
these other things that we've seen
come and go i don't see
a lot of like brilliant originality
to it that makes me say wow i've gotta
i've gotta
spend a lot of time engaging this new
movement
um it's you know it's it's interesting
i've actually you know
been to talks by graham harmon and asked
him questions
and you know it's okay um
it's uh i think it had a bit more
currency about five years ago than it
than it does now but who knows maybe
maybe
they'll produce some uh other stuff that
that really
you know grips people and and becomes a
major
new metaphysical movement so
oh mark mark smith is here glad to see
him
um patricia asked how did marx turn
hegel's idealism into dialectical
materialism
i mean how did marx turn bits and pieces
of hegel's philosophy into
uh you know cobbled together stuff that
later on gets called dialectical
materialism
he picked and choosed what he wanted to
and then critiqued other things and
you know um got some things right and
something's wrong
and uh it was deliberately polemical to
anybody else
who was around me you look at how he
treats other hegelians
like you know in his theses on foyerbach
foyerbach was a hegelian right
so um that's that's probably a short
answer to that
nicholas asks are there any prolific
philosophers other than singer that
explore the question of how non-human
animals relate to humans in terms of
moral worth
uh yeah but some of them you're not
gonna be happy with
um because they say that animals are
basically
here for us but they qualify as prolific
philosophers going all the way back to
antiquity right
in cicero's uh
on the nature of the gods the stoic guy
balbus
says he presents this entire account of
like a stoic theology
and he says that um animal being is
therefore a rational being
that that's the way the stoics viewed it
they were pretty prolific
uh rene descartes pretty prolific guy um
thought that animals are basically meat
machines emanuel kant
thought that um you know very prolific
guy as well thought that you know
animals our care for them really has
more to do with
uh you know like our own character it
doesn't we don't really care about them
intrinsically
heidegger thought that animals lack a
world you know i mean so there's plenty
of people out there
maybe what you mean is are there other
philosophers who are quite prolific
and are focused primarily on arguing for
animal rights or taking animals into
consideration
and yeah i mean there's plenty of people
um i mean i think you could just google
that and find
quite a few i'm that's not like an area
of my expertise but i will say my fellow
wisconsinite aldo leopold with his land
ethic
certainly espouses something like that
right read san county almanac or or
other
um things like that but it's not really
an area of my
my specialization so i don't i don't
have too much to tell you but i think
you could easily find that out by by a
search
so all right let's uh
get back to here we go
um noyen asks another
question where can we learn about greek
pottery and their concepts again not not
really in my area of expertise so i
don't i don't know
greek i'm sure there's plenty of books
out there on it
um rt whitby here's a good question what
do you think about philosophy professors
that are apathetic about teaching
philosophy and don't care about
improving their teaching ability
so i do have a video about that it's
specifically
focused on what we call service classes
right it's one of my dr
sadler soapbox talks um
so service classes are like you know
intro to philosophy or ethics or
critical thinking or
you know other things that are like low
level where it's not just philosophy
majors
and it usually satisfies some kind of
general ed requirement or
or elective and i think those are the
hardest but the most important classes
to to teach
effectively because that is where we
as members of the philosophy
whatever you want to call it you know
discipline profession guild
what have you traditions that's where we
get to
introduce what what we think is
important
to younger people who
don't necessarily come in believing that
it is important and actually may be
quite
anxious about taking philosophy or
they've been told that philosophy is
basically
bs and it's going to lead them astray or
they view it as a waste of time so
so if if we do a bad job in
approaching those sorts of pedagogical
situations
then um we set up a negative feedback
loop where the students are like so
a great example you know you talk about
professors being apathetic about
teaching philosophy
there's quite a few professors that are
burnt out and it's their own damn fault
that they're burnt out because they
expected too much of their students too
much
like they thought they were teaching
graduate students who are
majoring in philosophy when really
they're supposed to be teaching a you
know a broad swath of of
undergraduates who are not majoring in
philosophy but could be
potential lifelong learners and
appreciators
and they wanted you know the professors
wanted to do things their way and if the
students didn't measure up they treat
the students like crap
and make them feel like crap and then
surprise surprise the students don't
like philosophy
right i mean imagine if you had a music
teacher or
a gym coach who treated you that way you
probably wouldn't like what they're
what they're trying to uh suggest you
ought to ought to do
if you go the other way and you teach a
class
and you're like listen i i know that
you know none of you are here because
you've
actually wanted to be here except for
maybe that one guy in the back who's
going to ask all the questions because
he's already into it but
the bulk of you are not that into it
i'm going to do my best to communicate
not just my
passion for this stuff but also to give
you resources
and provide helpful examples and we're
going to have discussions that center
on the text and when you don't
understand a word i'm not going to make
you feel stupid
but i'm gonna actually like help you
figure out what the word means and how
it fits in
to what's being said that creates a very
powerful positive feedback loop and you
can go
down you know the halls in a university
and and
poke your head into classrooms and you
can tell the difference between
those two dynamics as they're happening
um so i you know i what do i think about
professors who are apathetic i think
they shouldn't be
teaching i think i think you know
especially in a time when we have
um so many people out there who would
like to teach
and would like to get paid for it let's
kick the dead weight out
you know but that's not going to happen
i'm not in charge of that sort of thing
all right um
luna seraphine says i'm a rising high
school
junior who's interested in self-studying
some great philosophical works that's
great
i've started on plato's republic and
planning to write
a critique of books three or four with
some inspiration from karl popper's open
society and its enemies do you have any
tips for writing a philosophical essay
yeah i mean that is the sort of thing
that you should do
and then later on down the line you can
be very embarrassed about
buying into popper's terrible reading of
plato but
i mean i did lots of stuff like that
where
you know it's good practice right um you
you uh you go through a phase you write
something you try something out
and you know it's okay to to um
to fail and and to think that you
succeeded but but
actually i mean if you do read plato's
republic closely you'll and you go to
pop you'll be like wow this guy
what was going on with him
but yeah you should do that i think
that's that's that's great
um do i have any tips for writing a
philosophical essay
always keep your audience in mind don't
assume that your audience agrees with
you it's up to you
to you know apply yourself to the
rhetorical situation
and make a case and you should also
think about what would be counter
objections that somebody else could
bring
in this case you would want to think
about well what what does plato actually
have in his text where
socrates or glaucon or whoever could
respond to
what popper's saying and you could also
think about well
what would i say about what popper is
saying is he being fair
is he on point about stuff so
you know philosophical texts often have
a lot of dialectic of that sort
in there uh armand
do you think we should study philosophy
in a chronological and historical order
you can but you don't have to it depends
on what you're
aiming at i mean if your goal is to like
you know
map out the history of philosophy up in
your head then i suppose that's
that's you know an important thing to do
i know i didn't study philosophy in
chronological order
um and i turned out just fine and i know
a lot of other people who didn't but
um you know some people like that that
approach to things um
you're going to realize that it's not so
simple as just like
figuring out who came first and wrote
what work at what time because there's
all these movements and
interactions and sometimes a text will
lay
you know fallow and unlooked at for
hundreds of years and then somebody else
will pick it up and do something with it
but yeah i mean it's a good thing to to
like understand the chronology i'll put
it to you that way
um
[Music]
k-funk how can one read philosophy
without getting
overwhelmed by ex overwhelmed about
existence um dad i don't i don't
actually know i don't understand what
getting overwhelmed
um about existence means like is that
like the the text applies to you and you
get worried
about it or like i've known people who
read descartes meditations one and two
and they then say oh crap
maybe i am just in a dream maybe there
is an evil demon that's deceiving me and
they and they don't actually like follow
out
descartes um arguments um i guess that
could be
part of it maybe part of if you're the
kind of person who reads a philosophical
text and then you're automatically like
infected with the author's ideas maybe
you have to develop some critical
distance and say
just because it's in the text doesn't
mean that it's automatically
right roughly bumble asks in my first
readings of the republic
what was my favorite books is that book
still your favorite today for similar
their dissimilar reasons now that is
that is a tough one
okay so when did i first read the
republic
sometime
sometime as a whole sometime in
early on in graduate school because we
read parts of it as an undergrad
and you know i thought it was
interesting
um i think that the parts
that i like the best if we have to talk
about books
book four early on because you've got
that
discussion of the virtues and what they
include and the whole
you know like model of the soul and the
city with the parts working together
i found that very attractive and
fascinating and by the way my
undergraduates
when i when i have them read it and i do
that in quite a few classes
often find it fascinating as well
is that my still my favorite book of
the republic i mean i really love
teaching that but
that's also in part because the students
respond to it well
um
i guess it probably is quite frankly i
mean there's other really cool stuff
going on book seven
allegory of the cave right um the
degenerate
um uh cities in in book
eight you know the discussion about
education
moving away from the ideal city the real
ideal city by the way
and this goes back to the question about
the popper thing the real ideal city and
plato is not the the city of the
republic it's it's actually the earlier
more primitive city discussed in book
two
and socrates responds to glaucon saying
oh the people won't have any relish for
their meets and he's
oh so you want the the city that has you
know excessive desires let's see if we
can make that work
i mean that's all cool stuff but i guess
that book four is still
the most interesting for me all right
um
made of clay any books that speaks on
the issue that being as dispassionately
objective as one can be
isn't actually a good way to get at
reality that you can't actually separate
your feeling from the objective
um i mean basically all of
existentialist philosophy
right um i and on that i would
definitely look at people like you know
una muno
and and chest off and and um
you know kierkegaard is is important in
that respect
um i mean what you're talking about is
is affectivity
and and um when you talk about
objectivity
objectivity can mean a million different
things for people um
but let's let's change it up and say
rationality
so you know classic virtue ethics
whether it be
aristotelian stoic
christian or others
has as one of its main goals to
understand
and to reintegrate
the affectivity and the re you know
rationality of the
human being so i would say
all of that tradition as well and it's
flowing forward into the
medieval times um
i mean even descartes thinks that the
passions of the soul play an important
role
right that's why i wrote a book called
the passions of the soul
which are types of thought so there i
think there's a lot of resources out
there for that
uh lyndon asked do i find it disturbing
that so much of
what is written about philosophers is
holcomb
doxa etc um
do i find it disturbing not really
um i mean it is a little discouraging so
we'll use stoicism as an example right
i used to spend more time
participating in the facebook groups
on stoicism and there's a number of them
out there
there's the the real big one stoic
philosophy run by donald robertson
there's another one that
is sometimes an open group closed group
it's another big one just called
stoicism
there's applying stoicism there's uh
stoic parents there's there's all sorts
of
stoic groups and i would say
that at this point in time you know when
i and this is not a scientific like
look at it or sampling but when i go
you know 90 of the stuff on there is is
garbage you know it's people like
sharing fake quotes
uh sometimes not even getting the
pictures right you know it's epicurus
instead of epictetus or
um carcala instead of marcus aurelius
and they're selling coaching packages
and
you know they they write some or they
you know they they write some little
blog post and it's mostly
mostly you know off base um
i mean i could get upset about that or i
could say well this
this area is probably not a good use of
my time
i'll just keep doing what i'm doing over
here and
it's unfortunate but you know that
instead of the cream rising to the top
that a lot of turds rise to the top
but you know that's that's the internet
age um what are you gonna do
i mean at any given point in time if you
go through a library
um a lot of the secondary literature on
philosophy is
not particularly great there's some
that's really awesome but
you gotta like weed through it um
you know you you can you know allow that
to
dismay you or you can say well you know
you just gotta
keep putting out the good stuff and
that's that's what i do
um
all right let's see here
rob says what do the stoics think about
forgiveness and self-forgiveness
they don't talk about that a lot i think
if you want to see what stoics think
about these sort of things you want to
go to stoic texts
so you know you would look to see what
epictetus says or seneca says or
what's in the uh discussion of stoic
ethics in aries didymus or see what
cicero has to say on it
um i wouldn't frame it so much in terms
of forgiveness
as rather in terms of like
not allowing things to you know get to
you
or overlooking slights or or stuff like
that
um so there's not an awful lot
using the words forgiveness could you
read some stuff
in maybe but
there's not a big tradition of that
linden is the influence of heraclitus
nietzsche and hegel small very small i
mean
heraclitus who knows what the hell he's
actually saying
anybody who claims that they they have
got like you know exactly what
heraclitus meant
is full of crap uh or you know just
hasn't read the text well enough and
they got
they got it from somebody else who's
full of crap um it'd be cool if we
someday found heraclituses on nature and
we could
actually like see a systematic thing
about it but
you're not going to get hegel or
nietzsche in any
real way from from heraclitus you know
other than the idea that like
things are in flux but heraclitus isn't
the only person to say that
ancient ancient times right the
epicurean atoms are all
kind of in flux right they're all
falling in the void right stoicism there
are
there there there aren't you know like
fixed substances
the way they are aristotelian stuff so
it's it's not a
it's you know to say those sorts of
things it's fun to like
push it back to heraclitus because he
sounds cool but
there's not i don't think there's an
awful lot of heraclitus
influencing these guys um
august says a question i have is how
does hegel's scholarship see the work of
jeanette polita i've been reading
uh genesis and structure and some say he
had a bad reading and influence to lose
poorly in this way
some say i mean some say anything you
want who's who says that uh you got to
go to the sources
and then say is this person full of [ __ ]
or is this person full of [ __ ] right
um i mean who cares if some say right
now influence to lose poorly in this way
i mean deleuze himself is a pretty
original character so i
i don't think that hip elite influenced
to lose
all that much i think duluz takes some
things from hip elite and from kojev and
from
and from and from and from right and
then does his own thing
afterwards um philosophy often doesn't
work in quite such a
blocky manner i mean how does hegel's
scholarship see the work of jean epoli
there's no
like assemblage out there called hegel
scholarship
there's all sorts of people working on
hegel coming at it from different
directions some of them don't even read
it elite you know
some of them do i think hippolyte is you
know pretty good
um he was kind of a standard source when
back when i was in grad school
but so was stanley rosen and so was um
you know uh kozhev in his own own right
and so we're a bunch of other people
you know you you go and you see i mean
even gautama wrote essays on hegel right
so
so you go and you like look at what it
is that he's saying
and you a smarter approach is generally
to say well i agree in this
thing and i disagree here you know that
that's the way we typically
do things but there isn't any like
grand cabal of hegel scholarship that's
all in consensus about things
um instead there's like you know there's
societies
but they there's nothing like an
international
agreement on on these these matters
uh thanks dennis that's that's nice of
you
um all right let's look down
lunar seraphine if plato's system of the
sole hierarchy ensures that the best of
citizens become guardians what happens
if a guardian turns out to be a bad
ruler get rid of them
seems pretty straightforward right you
weed out the bad eggs
um and you know the the best of the
citizens
aren't necessarily the guardians the
guardians are the best people to be
guardians
it's not that they are intrinsically the
best and that the other classes are
oh they're not very good at all no the
each class
does what it is best at right that's the
whole idea
behind it so best is is uh not an
absolute but a relative term there
um riley asked how would you convince
somebody the importance of studying
philosophy i probably wouldn't
i wouldn't try to convince them of that
um
i mean you can be there for them when
they screw up and you can say
you know like here here's a great
example so a colleague of mine
was having trouble with some of her
other colleagues
and i ended up bringing up a passage
from anselm
just from one of the letters that i was
you know looking at at the time for a
paper that i was writing
and she was like dumbfounded you know
and i said well i mean this is right
there in the text you can take a look at
it you can you know go further with it
if you want to
and she did she you know she read some
ansel anselm then she got into maria
zambrano
and and wanted to work on her and we
never actually did the the joint work we
were planning on doing with that but
um it's more like you know you don't
convince people that that philosophy is
worth studying you allow it to
step in when it when it when it should
and help them out
all right uh mark asked do you think
it's possible to have a viable ethics
without a conception of the highest good
even if only as an idea providing a
formal principle or would that then be a
metaphysics
um so viable ethics right
an ethics that you could actually could
live out and not screw your life up
with without some conception of a
highest good
i mean you could have various
conceptions
of highest good and then you have to
like juggle them or prioritize between
them
which you know a lot of uh classic
ethics actually have passages
doing that or saying ah it all boils
down to this like look at you know
mill and bentham with utilitarianism
they don't just assert
that you know uh pleasure is the good
pain is the bad or however else we've
understood happiness and misery
they also like make an argument to say
everybody else by the way they're doing
this but just not in a
consistent way um
yeah i guess you could say that every
moral theory is gonna have
some notion of like
how you rank order goods or what's most
basic and something has to be at the top
you could leave it up to other people
like you know one of the classic
conceptions of what goes on in liberal
modernity
is the leaving it up to individuals to
decide but then there's still a decision
about well this is the highest good for
me at least at this time right
so yeah
but would it be a metaphysics that's a
good question
i tend to think that metaphysics and
morality are more closely connected
than in our post-conscient era where we
want to say those are like subject to
two different critiques you know
uh i i tend to think that they're more
closely connected than we
we see you know
all right uh brah said i used to love
philosophy so greatly going to an
analytical school has killed my interest
do you have any advice for reviving love
for philosophy
read other books talk to other people
you have an entire internet
of potential interlocutors
um with lots and lots of content
why would you allow going to an analytic
school to so dominate your
development that you get turned off
there's there's nothing that says that
you can't read plato on the side
or descartes or whoever else you want to
right
like i say to people it's a free country
so if you're not getting what you want
from analytic philosophy
why not read other stuff analytic
philosophy is just one
tiny little corner you know a parochial
little spot in the vast
panorama just of contemporary philosophy
but also the history of philosophy
so and you you know i mean we live in an
extraordinary time even back in the day
if you didn't like what your
teachers were were teaching you would go
to the library
and there'd be all sorts of other texts
that they're not talking about that you
can just check out and read on your own
but now we have the internet right we
have all this
available content so there's nothing
holding you back from
reviving your your interest what were
you interested in before
go go back and read some of that right
uh tushar says how should one go about
dealing with the sheer terror and panic
solipsism
brings now it seems what we've seen
cannot be unseen
i mean i i just don't take solipsism
seriously
i don't know why anyone who was a
solipsist would feel
terror and panic about it because if you
really were a solipsist there's nothing
to worry about you're
you're it all right so
um is it that you're worried that maybe
everything else is a figment
well if that's the case then who cares
who i mean who cares what i think who
cares what anyone thinks they're not you
they're not the solipsism you know um
so i'm not really sure how to how to
address that one
ai webb i'm new on philosophy where
should i start
um i've got a whole bunch of videos in a
playlist called self-directed studies so
i always say start with plato but you
don't have to start with plato you can
start anywhere you want
uh byron again um any thoughts on the
recent moto proprio from
pope francis yeah so we have a little
bit of explanation here
pope francis has given direction about
um worship in in liturgy
in in the catholic church i think it's a
great document
i think that i'm perfectly cool with
de-emphasizing the latin mass it's sort
of like one of these things where
this is why we can't have nice things
because so many
silly [ __ ] you know people
have been emphasizing how how cool the
latin mass is and how it's
it's the the best thing you know and if
you don't speak latin you don't need a
latin mass
the mass should be in the vernacular it
has been and
if you want like an ancient liturgy go
to a maronite
uh catholic church right where they have
much older liturgies
parts of which are in syriac and that's
a lot closer to the original church than
the
the latin mass you know so i'm
i'm cool with it i i think it's a great
touchstone for figuring out who the the
nutters are uh
who've been indulged for far too long
within the church
i think another thing that's really cool
in the motor proprio
is that those who are going to celebrate
the mass
not only have to have a good working
knowledge of latin so they're not
stumbling over the
the verbiage right and a good good
knowledge of latin doesn't mean
ability to read thomas aquinas it means
ability to read across the board
but they have to be motivated by charity
in their hearts
so if it's some some you know snotty
conservatives
who look down upon other catholics or
say that you know
pope francis isn't really the pope or
anything like that
that's not charity in your heart that's
really
being you know putting yourself outside
of the community
so i think the mode appropriate i'm cool
with it i i think that
you know a lot of a lot of silliness has
been indulged far
too long for um
probably good reasons
at the time but it turned out to be bad
reasons
and that um it's time to clean house
you know it's also time to clean house
on on bishops who don't do their jobs
uh in protecting the the laity against
predatory priests it's also the time to
clean house on a lot of accounts
that that's my view so
all right uh plato tickates
what is a fantasy book or series that
you think should be adapted into a
series
or a movie or is one you would really
recommend
okay well that's that's interesting i
mean i think there's a lot of fantasy
um books that i've talked about in
worlds of speculative fiction that i
would love to see
not a movie movies are too tough movies
you get
at best like two hours
and good um
world building can't be adequately done
in two hours
even the lord of the rings you know
which was a pretty good movie series
had to fudge on on some stuff um
what you really need is something like a
a
tv series so
game of thrones you know slash song of
ice and fire they've already screwed the
pooch on that one
right that that one's dead they're gonna
come out with some like
alternate stuff nobody wants to see it
because they
you know they they did such a terrible
job with the last few seasons of it
um earth sea has been done before i
think earth c
could be done again uh but it would have
it probably would have to be a tv show
um gorman ghost you know the the trilogy
by merman peak i mentioned that um
earlier
that's been done um by the sci-fi
channel and they did an okay job but it
probably could have been done a lot
better as well
dune probably shouldn't be a movie dude
should probably be a tv series
um what else
um you know
i'm recently i did the
first three big thick books
of um our scott backer's
second apocalypse that would be pretty
good
too to do and i think you could stop
at the the third book without going into
the
great ordeal four books that come
afterwards
so i think there's a lot out there but i
but i think that the basic point is
you you really can't do it well
um with a movie it's really tough to
pull off
doing it in a movie and so you know i'm
not into superhero movies
um and and i kind of you know the few
marvel movies that i've watched i've
actually found pretty disappointing
as somebody who was into marvel comics
back in the day especially the x-men
crap you know
i found that really really poorly done
in almost every case
um but you can say that the marvel
universe of movies is is sort of a
coherent
project and that's that's kind of that's
kind of good you know and that is
speculative fiction right
there are some great speculative fiction
um
shows out there already though you know
my wife and i are re-watching our way
in my case re-watching in her case
watching for the first time
through babylon 5 and
you know it holds up it's it's a good
series there are some places where the
the
dialogue writing is a little hokey and
obviously the costumes
oh man there's a whole conversation to
be had about that
but the general writing is really solid
now i haven't actually we're not into
the fifth season
which was kind of thrown together at the
last minute so maybe i have to reserve
judgment about that
but it's it's uh pretty good overall
all right um
mr poncho are there any works in
aesthetics you find interesting or
consider foundational
i am not an aesthetics guy um so i don't
really have that much to say about
that i mean i've read works in
aesthetics
i've i've never actually taught a class
on aesthetics although i i probably do
need to develop one for milwaukee
institute of art and design
in the next few years but i don't know
a work that like covers
all the key issues or ideas
there's probably one out there but i i
just don't know what it would be
so uh the over giver have i ever read
claymont rosette
never even heard of them so no uh
serge says why did such great minds as
socrates and jesus who were
unjustly convicted choose death both
could escape and avoid death but it
feels like great minds quite often do
not respect earthly life i
i wouldn't say it's not about respecting
earthly life it's about
seeing something else as worth
sacrificing earthly life
for i mean if you want to know what
socrates actually thought about that
plato has a work called the apology and
xenophon
also has an apology of socrates um
you know it's i don't think it's it's
too hard to find out what their
their reasoning on that is
uh lyndon do you find there will be
blood to be a fair representation of
nietzschean ideas
vis-a-vis daniel plainview i i don't
know
i i haven't seen the movie for a very
long time was daniel the kid
who was brought up by the daniel
day-lewis
character um maybe maybe not i
i don't know it's been too long since
i've seen it
uh willow says my pep talk video really
helped me as an
early career researcher applying
philosophy to questions in ai and data
governance
do i have any advice for young
researchers
um yeah as a matter of fact
actually i do and some of it's going to
sound really cynical
[Music]
so first off don't allow people
that you're working with to screw you
over
it's very easy to
um to think that people are better than
they are
and many many professors
have built their reputations on the
backs of their graduate students doing
the
bulk of the work and giving them very
little credit for it
all across the in the sciences in the
humanities
even in the fine arts you know
where people had apprentices so make
sure
i think this is even more important what
you're generating
is intellectual property make sure that
your intellectual property
remains your intellectual property and
that you're recognized
for what you're doing i think that's
that's
something that because otherwise you get
screwed over
you know you you get placed into
compromising situations by people who
you looked up to
that takes a psychological toll on you
um
i've been fortunate to not have run into
that that much myself but i've seen a
lot of it
and i haven't run into it that much
myself because i'm kind of like i do
things on my own right
although i've been involved in
organizations where
i was definitely being exploited not not
with a you know like professor grad
student thing but
in other ways and it it puts a bad taste
in your mouth
right that interferes with you doing
doing the kind of work that you want to
do
so all right uh plato
clates why aren't you on your
university's notable alumni list i think
you qualify and should consider
contacting the university for this yeah
what do i care southern illinois
university um
what are what are they going to give me
you know it's a it's actually a dying
university
lakeland college has become lakeland
university
doesn't even have a philosophy program
anymore
i'm more you know working on all the
projects that i'm doing if somebody else
wants to put
put my name in for for that sort of
thing it's sort of like when people are
like
why don't the great courses people
contact you to to do a
uh you know series for them i don't know
i mean i i'm not in involved in those
decision-making processes if it really
bothers you
you talk to them you you send them a
letter they'd probably
care more coming from somebody else than
coming from
me saying hey why am i not in your thing
right
they might actually uh see that as a
reason not to have me in their thing
so very often you know you're not going
to be
particularly appreciated until
way down the line and you're super
famous and they want you to come
solve some problem for them for free or
you know
use you for publicity purposes or
something like that
all right uh quiz it's hot a rock uh
somebody who i follow on twitter
i'm a graduating philosophy student from
italy do you have any wise words for who
like me want to enter in academic
research and teaching
uh it's a tough time i mean i don't know
what the
the situation is like in europe i get
the idea that it's not
as bad as in britain or america
but the job market here in the united
states and in canada is just abyssal
um so
um get used to rejection and figuring
out how you're gonna
how you're gonna deal with that without
allowing it to like drag you down or
you know turn you resentful against the
people who you see
getting positions much of the academic
market is not a meritocracy at all it's
it's
more and more these days based on
pedigree
and contacts and you know factors like
like that
it's not a fair uh place and you are
you're probably going to get treated you
know in ways that you don't want to be
treated
that doesn't have i guess you could say
don't take that personally
because it really doesn't have to do
with you or your qualifications or your
potential
it has to do with a an unfairly
structured
choke point market unfortunately
it sounds kind of you know sad but
what are you gonna what are you gonna
say
um
anonymous do you think hegel was a
conceptualist depends on what you mean
by conceptualist and anytime somebody
asks me if somebody's an
iss of one form or another i always got
to know what they mean by it
um lyndon do i find alan
elaine badu interesting at all
marginally interesting
he's not he's not somebody who's really
that interesting to me
uh my wife has actually studied with him
and acted in his play
and he you know he seems like a very
nice guy but
um he's not somebody that i'm
i i view as somebody who i really want
to focus
a lot of attention on sleazy writer
stoicism is great but cynicism is not
stay virtuous and homeless fellow people
uh those are some pretty broad sweep
categorizations there's different kinds
of cynics i would recommend and scar
allen's book that i actually reviewed
just called cynicism to get a sense of
like the difference between different
kinds of cynics before before saying
something like that
um
[Music]
all right let me see who i haven't
answered
questions from because i we've got a lot
of questions
uh riley uh hegel really likes plato's
parmenides to what degree do you think
it is helpful to keep our amenities in
mind when reading through sense
certainty or perception
not very um i mean
have you read the parmenides it's
basically a dialectical exercise and
dialectical not in hegel's sense but in
plato's sense um i don't find it
i mean i i i read it from time to time
just because i read through all of
plato's works you know every so often
it's not a dialogue other than the very
first part of it where plato
or plato has socrates young socrates
talking with parmenides and parmenides
brings up some problems with
the theory of the forms i don't find it
very interesting at all
but i don't find this is very abstract
stuff very very interesting
there's a lot more going on in sense
certainty and perception i'd say than
what's going on
in the parmenides right
so let's see
antonio asks have i read oregon thinks
play as a symbol of the world
i have not uh as a matter of fact i'm
kind of
that's kind of intriguing because oregon
fink what do we associate him with
the sixth cartesian meditation um which
is you know
essentially like about husserole
and husserl's cartesian meditations
piece and husserl is a very very dry
writer and fink himself is not
you know he's not somebody i would
associate with
um what is what is the words there play
um that sounds more like you know people
like
johann huizinga you know so maybe now i
actually want to read that
um that sounds kind of interesting
hopefully it won't be like
i'm trying to remember there's another
phenomenologist
and he's got a big thick book roman
ingarden
about the the uh
literary work of art and holy crap
is that boring to read i mean it's it's
interesting as a project
you know it's more boring than reading
bentham with his
endless lists and categorizations
um that's one of the problems in some
phenomenology
um rob asks i'm starting to realize a
lot of the existentialists are pretty
passionately anti-hegelian
i'm curious if you have any thoughts or
commentary on that trend yeah so
so a good thing to keep in mind is hegel
was a
really really big deal in the 19th
century
and um you know
there were like any other philosopher
who's a big deal he attracted a lot of
you know second rate to like bottom rate
thinkers
who were hegelians just like people jump
on to
other trends right so for every um
duluz out there there are some really
interesting
deluge interpreters and then there's
like people who just keep you know
talking about body without organs over
and over again and
deteriorating and they've learned a
lingo but they don't have any clue about
what they're talking about right
and if you like say where is that in
this work
you know they they can't they don't read
the works they like watch videos or
you know uh read little snippets or
things like that
so that was what was going on with with
hegel not not every hegelian
was actually up to snuff and
i kind of think like say take
kierkegaard for example kierkegaard goes
after hegel
but he rarely does so in the
mean-spirited
off-base way that say schopenhauer does
instead kierkegaard points out that he
thinks that hegel's got some things
wrong like for example in um
fear and trembling right hegel
is sort of an emblem of his time
by saying that we begin with faith and
then we move
past it right and that's that's you know
straight hegel
so he's disagreeing with him about
something key that you're going to find
in the phenomenology
in the lectures on the history
lectures on the uh philosophy of
religion
um but he's not attacking hegel as such
as a matter of fact there's a lot of
hegel and and
dialectical uh stuff in kierkegaard
um he is going hard after the hegelians
of
his time in denmark and germany
um nietzsche you know criticizes the
birth of tragedy later on as being
hegelian
but there i think he means sort of like
a you know
boiled down not very good hegelianism
rather than saying that it's it's not
equal to
to hegel um i mean who else is really
anti hegelian
in a serious sense among the
existentialists
dostoevsky will have characters from
time to time who will talk
and they're really attacking like the
hegelianism that had filtered into
russia more than anything else
[Music]
chest off
treats hegel like any other
metaphysician
um who else
heidegger is actually a great admirer of
hegel he thinks that hegel is is a very
important metaphysician who's
contributing things
um sartre uses hegel
simondo bouvoir uses hegel
so i'm not i i you know i think you can
say that there is an
anti hegelian in a very broad sense
um motif but it's it's kind of
it's kind of uh messy right
all right uh another question about
aesthetics from from
jacob jacob or jacob or whoever do you
have any favorite authors who mainly
discuss
aesthetics do you have any interest in
the subject i do have an interest in the
subject but i'm a complete amateur
i mean i kind of like reading people who
are
philosophers but also novelists
um and what they have to say about it or
or you know
artists in other respects like you know
rainer maria rilke or
or jean paul sartre and simone de
beauvoir or
iris murdoch you know um i i think they
have interesting things to say but
i'm not i'm not that's not one of my
areas of specialization
all right um columbus have you ever
looked more into kyoto school and more
contemporary japanese philosophers no i
have not
um i think you've asked me about that
before but no um
and it's a matter of finding the time i
got a million other things to do
you know um
qwerty i just found out about this
channel two hours ago and i watched the
stranger video
after reading the novel today well good
i'm
glad glad you did that ah mr poncha were
you ever tempted to switch from
philosophy to classics
classical studies i feel like you would
have been a great classicist
no i never i never was tempted to do
that
and that's an interesting question um to
ask
and and why i'm turning a little bit
light out because it's getting dark in
here as as we
storms are rolling in here in milwaukee
um i was never tempted to
to move from philosophy to classics
in part because that was not an option
when i was an undergraduate we didn't
have classics
and at that time the languages that i
was working with i was i was trying to
learn
mandarin but doing a very half-assed job
with it
um i was you know i was improving my
french you could say
rather than learning french and reading
a lot of french literature and i was
i was teaching myself german towards the
end of it
and then in the year that i i
just worked and you know exercised and
worked on languages and then i got to
grad school in 1995
and i you know i was in philosophy and i
was having a great time with that
um i
effectively taught myself latin um
using you know like a grammar and and
you know teach yourself latin stuff
and then working on on texts and
manuscripts and translating
with greek i studied with the classics
department
and i did do some of my philosophical uh
classes like for example on aristotle's
nick of mccain ethics i i read it in
greek with
uh brian johnson who is a professor i
think he might may still be a professor
down there now
um i studied plato's symposium in greek
with
rick williams who i believe is retired
by now he's
if he's not he's certainly very old um
and they were in the classics department
but i i never was tempted to like leave
because i
was doing great in philosophy you know
and i didn't have the intention of
becoming a class assistant anyway
um so you know uh there's
there's that going on i was tempted
when i was an undergraduate to i was a
mathematics and philosophy major
and i was tempted to drop the philosophy
major and to take up a writing major
and i talked with carl elder who's whose
poetry class
i was allowed to sit in on and i went to
his office and i
i asked him i said you know i think i'd
i think i'd like to be a writer
um i'm thinking about dropping
philosophy and switching to english and
he said oh that's a terrible idea
that's why he said oh these these
friggin writing students i mean you're
in class you see what they're like
they're awful and i was like well that's
that's
okay that's that's a little harsh but um
what do you think i ought to do and he
said oh no stay a philosophy major
that way you'll actually have some crap
to write about
all these people they like write their
lives and all that and i'm so sick of
hearing about all this
this burial crap and now
i i actually followed his advice not
really i think for the reasons that he
had had suggested um but it was kind of
a funny
thing to say wasn't it and and i think
that they're
probably it probably was the a good
thing for me to do to stick with
philosophy
so all right um
lamont rogers says why do you think so
many professional philosophers of
economic
views at odds with the economic
mainstream does it bother you that they
do
i don't know that that's true i don't
know who the economic mainstream is i
suspect it varies
from country to country and place to
place and that what we call the economic
mainstream in one place is is a rather
parochial
representation does it bother me that
philosophers differ from
what you know economists think not at
all because economists are very often
living in this this you know you want to
talk about a world of abstractions
that's totally divorced from
real life uh economists are probably one
of the best
groups for that way more than historians
or
psychologists or sociologists or even
people just you know studying finance
right
so no it doesn't bother me at all as a
matter of fact we probably
do need some good pushback from not just
you know philosophers but other people
saying hey you economists
you really leave a lot of stuff out
all right um
james are there any conservative
philosophers you like do you find
anything interesting in conservative
thinkers
depends on how you define conservativism
um
yeah i mean is hobbs a conservative
maybe maybe not i teach about hobbes all
the time
i teach john locke in in classes you
know
um but it depends on what kind of
conservative conservative is one of
those words that
it's really a weasel word these days
because present-day conservatives
are not conservative by any means
they're more
uh libertarian or fascist or something
else right theocratic
um just outright selfish [ __ ]
you know pick whatever you want but
they're they don't live up to
conservative principles
and they've like flip-flopped their
position in recent decades on
all sorts of things like say gun control
or protecting the environment you know
things that
were part of conservativism 40 years ago
are now you know what they're against
you know i can tell you this too if we
had had this this
coveted problem back in the reagan years
conservatives would have been four masks
and four vaccinations
they wouldn't be loonies out there you
know coming up with all this crazy crap
that they get from
fox news or oan or pick whatever website
you like
so conservative covers a lot of ground
right and
you know i there there's when you say
like
like in what way like as in endorse
their ideas
like as in think that they're worth
studying i mean i
teach hobbes a lot but i don't like
hobbes in the sense of endorsing his
ideas
i think he's interesting to read and
interesting to to study
um all right let's
who do we have here jordan says have you
read any iranian or persian philosophy
i think the only person i've actually
read is omar hayam
and that would be the rubaiyat and it's
in the translation by fitzgerald which
you know is quite different than the
original text so no
not really um zwell
says would you consider making videos
about your own views
i have made videos about my own views um
so you know quite quite a few of them
you just gotta look for it
um
any opinions on bart's theology um i
haven't looked at bart for years and
years but i
i never he was never anybody he was
never somebody who i could take
seriously as like an option
for for me in terms of how to understand
christianity and scripture and stuff
like that
um very influential guy though so
ivan says i'm a post-grad in humanities
which
did get burnt out of his doctorate and
did drop the ball when he was in the
last year of my candidature so i retake
my research
that's a good question i think that
depends on a lot of factors
what do you have to lose by doing it
maybe maybe like a year of your life
um does it matter to you to that
you know that you finish it um
now that you're no longer burnt out if
if it does then i would say
you know and it's financially feasible
then why not do it you know it's it's
nice to
check off things that have been left
hanging for a long time that maybe you
feel bad about
is it going to like make your life uh
automatically better
i don't know it depends on what what
field you're going into i suppose right
so all right
uh sam what's your view on on cognitive
behavior therapy in relation to
practicing stoicism
um
you know so the the cognitive revolution
has some of its roots in some readings
of some
parts of stoicism right famously albert
ellis was into epictetus
it doesn't appear that he was like you
know all that much into
other stoics um but there are some
connections
and there are some people like donald
robertson he's got an actual book on
on stoicism and cognitive behavior
therapy which
um i think could be quite helpful to to
read
he's a practicing person who puts both
of them together
um walter matt waychuk um is an rebt
person
who also knows a good bit about stoicism
and brings them
together um so you know you can do that
i will say something really interesting
and i've brought this up before that
donald robertson said to me in a
conversation one time
he said you know cognitive behavior
therapy and rebt rational emotive
behavior therapy they have a literature
right there's that burns feeling good
book
there's albert ellis's books and stuff
like that
but people don't treat these books like
they treat epictetus as discourses or
seneca's letters or
on you know the happy life or on the
shortness of life or marcus oralis's
meditations they don't keep coming back
to them over and over again
they might you know for example um
re-read a chapter of burns is feeling
good because they want to like
look at the exercises that he's
prescribing or something like that
but nobody reads it as like literature
that's worth
reading stoicism people read it as
stuff that's worth reading and rereading
and rereading
over the course of their life so that's
an important difference and they said
what is what is it that stoicism has
that these therapeutic approaches
don't have that's an interesting
question to to mull over
so all right um
let's see here patricia says have you
read paula frierry the educator on the
political nature of education
and the use of questions to unveil and
reflect upon the experiences of
educational practice i mean everybody
had to read him at one point
in time right because he was such an
important influential
writer in in philosophy of education and
so yeah i've read him
and uh i think there's you know
interesting things that he has to say
um so yeah he's
sort of a part of i would say he's part
of the
curriculum when you have philosophy of
education in in a lot of places
uh neil this is a tough one
worst popular philosopher today
in your view i don't know i mean
where we're where do we draw the line
between popular philosopher
and just like bullshitter um
i mean if we're going to extend it very
very widely
i will say that that conceptual james
guy is
he's just a nut and the stuff that he
says is just like
you know drooling garbage
uh and he's getting bankrolled by by
people to do that sort of stuff and like
appearing in conservative
forums and then just spouting stupid
things about like how
hegelianism leads to critical race
theory and just just crazy crap like
that
but you know it's sort of like
whack-a-mole i mean
as that guy gets bonked down because
nobody can
maintain that level of bullshittery for
very long
somebody else will rise in his place you
know
there aren't a lot of great popular
philosophers out there
who are saying anything that's that's
either like true or interesting or on
point so
yeah um
dennis asked nietzsche as the most
prescient poet philosopher with regard
to the present
conflagration uh i wouldn't say so
um i mean
[Music]
what do you mean by the present
conflagration the uh
you know worsening climate crisis the
covid
pandemic economic dislocations i mean
nietzsche has some things to say about
that but he's not he's not a a prophet
you know um who knew like ahead of time
what all the things that were going to
happen so
um neuen what are the
what are the initiation to okioses well
this is where
there's actually a book that you could
you could read and you can find lots of
blog posts talking about this as well
um hirocles the um
stoic philosopher he's he's the one who
writes the most about eukaiosis
i actually think that oikiosis is just
like one among many different tools
within the stoic toolbox and we
shouldn't like
you know try to make too much of it but
heracles is definitely the guy to go to
um here's an interesting one from
chandler how do you trust your own
judgments and smarter people disagree
with you on significant questions
um i mean how do i know they're smarter
you know just because they have a better
position
or they've written more books or i mean
they could be wrong couldn't they i mean
and for any smart person that we find
you can take sort of the skept the
classical
ancient skeptic position for every
argument there you can find an equal
counter argument for every smart guy
smart woman
smart whatever you can find an equal one
who's gonna say some other thing
i mean i think you have to you know you
have to build things out
and and you know do do a lot of uh
work and thinking things through
yourself and it is good
good to bounce your ideas off of other
people but
you know they're not necessarily an
oracle that automatically tells you the
truth so
yeah um
oh here's a good question from
apotheosis how do you think most people
judge the worth of a particular
philosopher's work is it possible for
example to have an elevated view of
nietzsche's philosophy
just because it appeals to you
personally so two different questions
there
um and yeah it's totally possible a lot
of people
read somebody and then they think
they're awesome because that person has
said what they already think and
probably done it in a more articulate
way
so if you already think that people are
basically
you know mean and dangerous and you read
hobbs and you're like oh this is totally
this totally makes sense man
yeah but maybe you're maybe you're wrong
and maybe hobbs is wrong right
so um there's a lot of people who do
that and they'll jump from philosopher
to philosopher
sometimes as they get disappointed
because they the first thing that they
thought about the philosopher
they had a you know misunderstanding
about what the philosopher was actually
saying and then they feel betrayed
right uh what plato called mistology
or they you know they actually grow a
little bit in their life and they're
like
yeah this this isn't doing it for me
anymore there's a lot of people who
who pick their their philosophies or
pick their
religions or pick their politics or pick
their whatever
on the basis of this jibes with me you
know
and and it's kind of a narcissistic way
to do things
um but it's it's pretty common now
the other question how do most people
judge the worth of a particular
philosopher's work
they don't do it on that basis because
most people have not read
any particular philosopher
so how do they judge the the value of a
philosopher's work assuming they have
any judgment on it whatsoever
it's a great question they accept
somebody else's testimony about that
and this is where we get into trouble
right when you've got crappy histories
of philosophy
great example of this the popper plato
thing right
when it comes to his criticism of of
plato popper is off base and
you know not to put too fine a point on
it basically full of [ __ ]
being polemical you know
misunderstanding plato
but if you if you haven't read the plato
and you've got the popper and you read
the open society and its enemies
you'll be like oh yeah this plato guy
sounds like a real bad guy
i should stay away from his philosophy
not knowing that popper wasn't actually
to be trusted on that
this is where people get into all sorts
of trouble right
trusting the wrong people about
um the value of philosophy
you know so you don't go to jordan
peterson about
dostoyevsky or nietzsche you go to
somebody who's
uh you know a better reader and scholar
you don't go to schopenhauer for
evaluating hale because
schopenhauer hated hagel's guts right
so and you also shouldn't go in the
other way to people who are like oh this
person is so
so wonderful you know everything's going
to crash since they're
like all the people who love saint
thomas aquinas who if thomas aquinas
were in the same room as them
he'd be like ramus get the hell out of
here
you don't have any understanding of what
it was that i was teaching you know
um so that's i i would say that's where
most people get their evaluations of
philosophy from
unfortunately wikipedia is is a you know
good part of that as well
and um the key for that is
you got to read people yourself you know
and then you can actually judge
all right uh jeff sullivan thanks for
doing these any thoughts about younger
people who only listen to older music
especially when there's no chance of
live music thanks for turning me on to
dio
i don't think there's any problem with
that i i mean
i'm you know i'm a metal head since i
was a kid
i do listen to other music
i don't have as wide an appreciation of
music
as many other people do but i you know
listen to and also play
on my instruments things from duran
duran
or liz fair or john cougar mellencamp
or pj harvey you know and i
you know i i go to see the some of these
acts we're actually going to be seeing
um hauling oats
uh pretty soon with i think with squeeze
so that's going to be a fun show you
know
there's nothing that says that you can't
you know enjoy whatever music that you
you want to but you know you might be
restricting yourself a little bit too
much
going to the one question though about
like is it okay to listen to bands that
you could never
actually see in the case of live music
well that's that's the case for
you know um all sorts of bands from
from the past if it was if it was okay
then to like
so there was this incredible nostalgia
when i was a kid
among my parents generation for music
from the 50s right
um and a lot of those bands were gone
so were they doing the wrong thing and
listening to that
even though they couldn't go to see the
acts in places i
i don't think so i think i think that's
perfectly fine
um all right
uh let's see let me scroll down a little
bit
oh here's another one from from chandler
having gone through many philosophical
phases yourself
what are your thoughts in identifying
with certain metaphors versus having a
more distant
attitude and withholding judgment it's
impossible to withhold judgment
altogether
you're committed i mean the
existentialists are right about this to
not make a choice
is to choose um and you're going to
choose what roland bart called the null
ideology you know just some something
that appears to be totally neutral but
isn't um i think it's good to actually
like explore
and find things that you
you know think are actually on point and
valuable and then
you know maybe you leave it behind or
you reject certain parts of it i'm i'm
an eclectic myself
so i i think that that's quite different
than just being you know i'm going to
hold back from everything else
all right um
[Music]
let's see what else i can take here
we're gonna be out of time pretty soon
um
nathan asked do you think like me that
stoicism without a deep concept of the
universal deity is fundamentally lacking
i know it's in my experience that trust
in a higher being is crucial to
maintaining my stoicism no i don't agree
with you i think it's
i think you could be a stoic without
some deep concept of a universal deity
the stoic god doesn't do much of
anything
anyway you know i mean if you actually
read the stoic text
you're not supposed to resort to
divination you know epictetus is very
clear about this
um you know you don't pray to the stoic
god
i mean you can have this sort of vague
sense that everything is arranged for
the best but
i mean marcus aurelius actually says
listen
adams or providential ordering i don't
care
i can still live like a decent human
being whatever it happens to be
so i don't i don't think you you know if
you find it's personally helpful to you
cool i mean i don't think it's it's a
really it's an interesting historical
feature of stoicism
i don't think that it's absolutely
needed for modern stoicism
all right uh
[Music]
a lot of questions here that it just
jumped down so i'm gonna
pick something that i can kind of go out
on
[Music]
um
let's see
okay so here's here's a an interesting
thing to go out on
i'm thinking this is sweet sv i'm
thinking of creating introductory
philosophic
philosophy resources for a volunteer
tutoring organization
by synthesizing books online sources to
explain given topics do you have any
thoughts and tips on how to summarize
philosophical concepts without being
misleading and just accomplish this
altogether
i anticipate putting a lot of time in
this so yeah
i do have some ideas first of all you
got to know your stuff
right um you if you're going to talk
about
a philosopher and a book you have to
have read the book and you have to
understand the book you can't go by
wikipedia articles or
other people's videos or podcasts or
anything like that you you've got to
know the
stuff so let's make that a basic
assumption
um make your video there's a
a thing that that experts who are not
really experts
often say about education oh videos
can't be any longer than five to ten
minutes
or people won't actually watch them
they're full of crap
if your content is engaging and people
are learning stuff they'll watch an hour
and a half i mean look people have been
watching this thing for
an hour and a half right um
so you know you you have to be able to
develop
engagement with your audience and one
great way to be able to do that
is to think about examples that they can
relate to
that's very helpful in teaching
philosophy
you can look for examples that are
already there in the author's texts
like for example when i'm teaching
kant's categorical imperative
kant has some examples we unpack those
and then we add some other ones
hey is it okay to you know tell a white
lie to your friend
because you don't want to go to their
party right um how does that what's the
maxim for that right so
we can explore those sorts of things and
i think that can be
that's very good pedagogy don't worry
too much about
the thing being slick and well produced
if you have good content people will
watch it
if you have bad content then or mediocre
content then
it doesn't matter how slick you make it
how many animations you introduce
it's still not good content because
what's being conveyed is something
intellectual
not just visual
and i would say you know think about
your
your curriculum like you say you're
planning on putting a lot of time into
it
and break it down into parts
and don't think that any one video
has to like carry all the weight so like
right now
i'm shooting videos i'm in the process
of shooting videos on
a speculative fiction story philip jose
farmers the lovers
and it's it's you know a novella so it's
about 150 pages
i've actually broken the videos down
into one two three four five six seven
eight
eight different key themes that are
being discussed
in these these videos um for i'm looking
at my
my desktop right now for
arthur schopenhauer's on the basis of
morality
i've got it actually i've got one two
three
four five six seven eight nine
thumbnails there waiting for me to shoot
the videos on
the other thing i'll say too is um
you know producing videos
is like anything else at first it's
going to feel really
artificial and you're not going to be
probably out the gate great at it but
it's going to get better over time so
don't allow yourself to get discouraged
by the initial things ask your ask the
people who are watching them
um do you find this helpful right so
instead of like
getting down on yourself because it's
not exactly what you
wanted see if if it satisfies a need
for other people and i think that would
be good
so i got to go i got to eat something
before my next
uh meeting with my patreon supporters
the philosophy chat for people at a
certain level
thanks for all the questions and
comments
and i will uh do this again
next month we've got some other cool
things coming up this month including
readings
from i don't think i've got the book oh
no i
have the mic resting on the book
readings from my book
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates
in france but we'll have some other
things going on too as far as online
events so
all right i'll see all of you and have a
good rest of the day or evening or
whatever it is where you are